[Musique]
bonsoir avec seal pour leur merci d'être
avec nous alors qui croire au
gouvernement sur ce sujet des retraites
est ce qu'on parle d'un cafouillage de
plus je sais pas si c'est un cafouillage
où une stratégie d'un côté bruno le
maire -ministre de l'économie qui veut
montrer un du volontarisme dans cette
réforme systémique des retraites pour
bien montrer que la france est une bonne
élève et rassurer à la fois les marchés
et les institutions européennes qu'ils
commencent à s'inquiéter du taux
d'endettement français ou bien elizabeth
bornes qui elle est du côté des
travailleurs et dit attendons la
croissance attendant la reprise de
l'activité pour remettre cette réforme
des retraites sur la table je crois que
chacun est dans son rôle et qu' il faut
malheureusement croire tout le monde
sachant qu'un arbitrage devrait être
fait en haut lieu
et visiblement compte tenu de ce qu'on
dit les partenaires sociaux ça ne
pencherait plutôt du côté de la ministre
du travail de dire attendons la reprise
de la croissance attendant de voir quels
seront les chiffres du chômage avant que
de remettre cette réforme systémique sur
la table et qu'en pensent les
partenaires sociaux et bien eu comme
s'était dit dans le reportage sont en
bloc contre le retour de cette réforme
des retraites compte tenu de
l'incertitude devant l'activité
économique
compte tenu aussi des nombreux plans
sociaux qui se sont accumulés 1 depuis
le premier puis le deuxième confinement
même si l'aide de l'état est là pour
aider les commerces et les entreprises
elle est parfois insuffisante elle ne
n'évitera pas de nombreuses familles
faillite de tpe de pme ou des plans
sociaux même dans l'industrie qui paiera
de toute façon une reprise lente
même si encore une fois bono le maire se
veut optimiste pour 2021 dans que la
france va rebondir très fort ça reste à
voir
alors pas les mêmes habits de part et
d'autre qui croire c'est en fonction que
vous êtes financier vous préférez croire
bruno le maire qui va pousser rapidement
cette réforme qui était dans les cartons
des manuels macron dès son arrivée à
l'elysée
et puis si vous êtes du côté des
syndicats du côté des travailleurs et
bien vous préférez croire la ministre du
travail qui parle le bon
en réalité cette réforme ne peut avoir
lieu sans l'accord majoritaire des
partenaires sociaux et des syndicats qui
aujourd'hui ont très bien compris que ce
serait une explosion sociale programmée
que de remettre cette réforme
extrêmement contestée déjà lors de son
premier passage avant la crise sanitaire
ce serait une folie politique que de
faire cela alors autre patate chaude 1
du gouvernement l'article 24 de la loi
sécurité on en parle tous les jours en
ce moment que souhaite réécrire
finalement emmanuel macron après les
grandes manifestations et les violences
du week-end dernier sauf que le
parlement lui rappelle un ses droits les
sénateurs en tête
alexis oui alors c'est ce fameux article
24 qui veut encadrer la façon dont le
l'image des policiers se seraient
utilisés de manière malveillante sur les
réseaux sociaux
cafouillage total déjà au sein de la
majorité qui a voté pour le texte de
sécurité globale y compris l'article 24
mai rétropédalage devant le tollé auprès
des associations de défense des droits
de l'homme avec un ministre qui ne sait
plus comment faire un premier ministre
qui parlait même d'une commission ad-hoc
pour réécrire l'article et puis des
parlementaires de la majorité qui ont
dit mais attendez nous nous sommes
parlementaire c'est notre travail
d'écrire de loi laissez nous faire notre
travail
et puis cette loi maintenant arrive dans
les mains du sénat le sénat à majorité
plutôt l air et entendent bien
s'approprier cette loi l'amendé la
réécrire enlever toute référence à la
loi sur la liberté de la presse de 1881
et il est imprimé leur marque pour
retoquer ou un ré écrire mais à leur
façon avec la navette parlementaire tout
simplement cette loi qui finira de toute
façon sous les fourches du conseil
constitutionnel
donc pourquoi vouloir outrepasser encore
une fois le jeu parlementaire c'est
assez symptomatique de ce quinquennat ou
l'exécutif prend toute la place et
laisse bien peu de place au législatif
merci alexis à paulin